revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia en 24 y nos acompaña esta mañana
de lunes Marta Moya Marta bienvenida un
gusto tenerla esta mañana vamos a abrir
Entonces revista de prensa con un tema
colateral que ha surgido tras el
fallecimiento de la Reina Isabel segunda
el pasado jueves y es que antiguo
barbuda país miembro de la cama que ya
tiene Carlos tercero como el nuevo jefe
de estado ha planteado un referendo de
Independencia Marta Buenos días Raúl Así
es abrimos con el Antiguo a server que
titula este lunes el Primer Ministro
promete un referendo para que el país se
convierta en una República el Primer
Ministro Gastón Brown hizo declaraciones
después de la proclamación del Rey
Carlos III anunciando que estaría bien
que los próximos tres años antigua y
barbuda impulse un referéndum para
conseguir esa Independencia a todas las
escalas una república presidencialista
condicionó todo esto Pues a que él se ha
reelegido en las elecciones del próximo
año
convertirse en una República no
significa que represente alguna forma de
falta de respeto a la monarquía se trata
simplemente de completar ese círculo de
independencia para garantizar que seamos
verdaderamente una nación soberana
antigua y barbuda se hizo independiente
en
1981 y ahora pues quiere el Primer
Ministro completar ese círculo de
Independencia con este movimiento con
este cambio después de la muerte de la
reina Isabel Marta pero vamos ahora con
el diario.es también de resalte ese tema
así es el diario punto es titula antigua
y barbuda celebrará un referendo sobre
sus lazos con la monarquía con la corona
británica esto destaca otra vez la
entrevista con el medio itv en las que
pues el Primer Ministro dice pues que no
sería un gesto de hostilidad y que si se
proclamará la independencia pues antigua
y barbuda continuaría siendo un miembro
comprometido de la cama Wells además
destaca que las relaciones entre Reino
Unido y esta nación pues son mutuamente
respetuosas e inalterables vamos ahora
con medio británico la cómo lo ven
entonces en desde Reino Unido con the
Guardian de Guardian titula antigua y
barbuda celebrará un referéndum
republicano dentro de tres años según el
Primer Ministro destaca el Guardian Pues
que gaston Brown firmó el documento
confirmando Carlos III como rey y
minutos después impulsó esta voluntad de
pues llevar a cabo el referendo dice que
esto ya lo había proclamado en abril en
una visita a Los Condes de wessex y
pidió además justicia reparadora
cambiamos ahora de tema Marta Porque en
cuestión de la guerra en Ucrania estos
últimos días se han reportado los
avances de estas tropas ucranianas está
contra ofensiva como también ellos
llaman que ha generado cruces y
acusaciones entre estos dos países
enfrentados están como es costumbre
también pues unos dicen una cosa otros
dicen otras se acusó mutuamente qué está
pasando el Kevin independent titula este
lunes
liberadas mientras las defensas rusas
colapsan en medio del Rápido Avance
ucraniano en el aulas de harkif dice que
cuatro días después de la contraofensiva
de Ucrania en harkis las tropas rusas se
han retirado lo que indica un colapso
total de las tropas en esta región del
país dice que es el logro más
significativo a granés en la guerra a
gran escala que ha impulsado Moscú vamos
ahora con el coso moscadia claro esto es
un medio totalmente alineado con el
kremlin y dice dejamos el cerco edición
mantenemos la defensa a lo largo de
oskol lo que realmente está sucediendo
en la dirección de la operación especial
en harkit dice que las fuerzas
ucranianas están bombardeando
infraestructura civil allí donde estaban
pues las tropas rusas y que El Avance
ucraniano dice este medio es en
contraste con el fallido intento
ofensivo en jerson y que aquí kiev lanzó
unidades ucranianas y mercenarios
extranjeros recién entrenados por
instructores de la otan repasemos
rápidamente el país Marta para termina
en Brasil que es lo que estamos
avanzando en nuestros titulares muy
rápidamente el país dice que Ucrania
dispara a posiciones enemigas panfletos
con instrucciones para Rendirse y dice
que las instrucciones son tirar un arma
a un lado quedarse quieto de pie
levantar las manos y cerrar la bandera y
gritar me rindo ahora si terminamos en
Brasil y Marta donde los fantasmas que
ha promovido el presidente bolsonaro
sobre la legitimidad de este sistema
electoral ha llevado que las fuerzas
armadas finalmente vayan a ser presencia
en los Colegios electorales el día de
estos o comicios no vamos a empezar con
Sao Paulo la foya dice este lunes las
fuerzas armadas realizarán un conteo
paralelo en tiempo real con tres tiendas
85 urnas que es la muestra que se han
planteado realizar Pues el ejército en
este día electoral del 2 de octubre dice
que después de que bolsonaro infligiera
este miedo del fantasma electoral
diciendo que el conteo no era totalmente
real y no era efectivo y sembrar a toda
esta duda aparte o sea a partir de un
posible fraude dice que esta es una
inédita en la historia democrática de
Brasil y que el personal militar se
trasladará a los colegios electorales
para tomar y enviar fotos de los códigos
QR de las urnas Y luego el comando de
Ciber defensa del ejército será el
órgano que pues elabore este conteo
Paralelo que hice rápidamente el
espectador Marta el espectador hace un
análisis con expertos hice los militares
el estamento que bolsonaro quiere como
árbitro en las elecciones dice que
bolsonaro acaba su mandato habiendo
querido convertir a las fuerzas armadas
en un soporte político de su gobierno
bueno Marta así las cosas entonces en
esta revista de prensa lo que resaltamos
el día de hoy mañana con más revista de
prensa Marta